[Music]
every other team in the world goes to
bed at night and this is what they see
Australis now their nightmare
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you think that is strong
what's the first name that pops into
your head is it this one and it looks
like device just like in the pistol just
going to stop the fly and he picks up
the device and Glee and device yet again
what about this of the flash Bob people
works though I'm an efficient limited
weapons
how sick is this program he's cooking
for the eight
this tournament and now we're getting
called
[Applause]
if it's neither of those it's got to be
this one and they get the timing down
I'm just movin up on the other side of
him and see if he's gonna be turning his
back at the house of one elf the alley
with the patients play coming out
flashbang is in there now
25 seconds headshot coming in from
siblings what complain hell he do he has
to find the bomb and make his way onto a
site and look at the angle here this is
not easy be alley way out and the Albany
gets shot down that big for the 103
watch Oh
whichever one it is there's a good
chance it isn't the name that was most
recently added to their roster he is a
little bit crazy and he does play a
little bit unpredictably at times so I
think it's gonna be super interesting
now that obviously like I think once you
get past the honeymoon period is where
it's gonna that's where the real test is
I think and one that some people still
aren't sure how to pronounce yeah
that one I just caught me off okay
Pacific but Morgan's just - you're
asking - there's a good chance that you
didn't think of good old magic soy as a
star player before he joined Astralis
but your opinion has definitely changed
this is the story of how seemingly
innocuous player turned a group of
talented but historically inconsistent
chokers into the greatest csgo roster of
all time this is the story of a magical
boy becoming a man
this is the story of magic honestly I
can't see why we shouldn't be the best
team in the world because we are the
best team in the world
[Music]
Amil magic rife never set out to become
a professional counter-strike player it
just kind of happened
growing up in Denmark he was exposed to
the game at a very young age considering
it was one of his friends and family's
favorite pastimes he was only eight
years old when he played 1.6 for the
first time and even then demonstrated a
natural affinity for the game it was in
2015 at 17 that majus then known as
majesty i got his semi-professional
start in the kings of nordic series he
went on to serve short stints in both
MTW and epiphany bolt before being asked
to stand in for sk gaming for the
remainder of ESEA Pro League season to
having just suffered the departure of
Danish up-and-comer config SK needed
someone to fill his slot so majus
obliged still people were unsure as to
how he performed there's something I'm
particularly distrust the players that
are in this team it's just that some of
them like magic boy I don't know that
well and this boy banders prior to
acquiring majesty i eske's pro league
record was oh and 11 by the end of the
season they had gone up to 6 and 16 and
were able to avoid relegation as a
result it was here in these online
matches that majus boy realized he was
capable of trading blows with the best
of them the problem is that he was
developing a reputation for being an
online player become his first land that
would all change that could be the final
nail in the coffin
zip ex coming in from CT spawn I know it
is sk-gaming knockout tqm on the second
day the fragbite masters
can you believe unbelievable after
guaranteeing himself a top 3 finish
Majesty I went on to face one of the
best teams in the world and fnatic can
put on a show-stopping performance it's
actually things of a law he can still
get to be a break now Crim's is just
going to arrive in time though to cut
him off from short fight magic seems to
have an idea what I saw was that holy
[ __ ]
I can't even help myself that was insane
eske may have lost the series but not
before Majesty made his first mark on
the professional counter-strike seen
online he's being comparable to the
likes of AZ and his flagging ability is
off this charts and that's sure I
learned this shows you what he is
capable of absolutely nuts around there
for magic boy
unfortunately eske's results were never
very good after that by mid-2016 they
dropped the roster entirely and majus
was invited to join Team Dignitas there
he joined Cajun B who astrologist
discarded in favor of gr b and convict
who was quickly establishing himself as
one of Denmark's greatest talents before
long Denmark's three hallmark teams were
vying for the title of the country's
best roster danish CS had entered a
rebuilding period and majus boy was
hoping to come out on top but the
competition was stiff
thus many good teams and the team I want
to play the least is probably a solace
or heroic because we know them so well
and we have played them so many times so
it's always like who have the best day
who's gonna win the problem was that
Majesty I wasn't considered one of
Denmark's tier 1 talents sure he was a
great player and no stranger to
brilliance and you can just see trying
to scour out every positional once he
knows he's gonna be getting pushed from
all angles and they all coming in
roughly at the same time hungry one man
is one and he fights the second now this
has just got a little bit interesting
Maddox can he go big when Nene PSC can
he picks up all four frags but he just
wasn't on the same level as some of the
country's best players look at a boost
they're gonna trying to over oranges no
it looked like flush was gonna put what
up but it's carryin this time that will
hold it off not typical in oranges to
Kerrigan it's Danny Kaye in his hand and
there they go for the knife and return I
think they tried it I literally think
the player that ran through from water
I'm not mistaken it was Dupree tried to
get the knife
much of this had to do with his
inconsistent play Majesty was known for
being a wild player one whose emotions
often got the better of him
this is a dangerous position to be in
they're all coming around the corner he
picked up the first headshot not gonna
go for the second one snatch will take
him out
Cajun had already fallen back he
couldn't really help him out up at the
corner there so a little bit unfortunate
because if Cajun could have been there
once magic is the first kill of Cajun is
there to repeat with the AWB it's very
hard for voters Pro to punish that's
kind of a setup and then in November of
2016
Majesty I had his day I don't think I've
ever seen VP diss defeated especially
not in the grand finals they just have
no clue what's hit them very very absurd
to be watching how could you do this
they still have a couple of flashbangs
left even on date this house here virtus
Pro it's now whatever just go for it
they're being flying as well make is
picking the one kill Snax going down
there it is data tough picking up a
piece and a Moscow the biggest victory
late for this team coming out of
epicenter things were looking all right
for Dignitas the issue is that about a
month later the stars finally aligned
between Astralis in the in-game leader
they'd spent years trying to acquire
glaive within a matter of weeks the
battle for Denmark was over with played
at the helm
astralis earned six top six finishes at
premier events one of which was a
long-awaited major win in January of
2017
where was majus you asked also at the
major his first ever but playing under
North since Dignitas dropped their
Danish roster in favor of a North
American one following a straws his
Serge
I don't think of ever in my life been so
nervous before so it was really
speechless when we finally close out the
game it was a bit more close than I
would have liked to but it was so
amazing to play and and get doing
despite making it out of groups North
suffered a gut-wrenching loss to virtus
Pro in the quarterfinals he's dropped
the bomb with 53 seconds to go into
three versus two for virtus Pro the flag
Cajun goes down Conn fake fight for your
life he finds tabs it's late he's got to
get to kneels and come back against
North after that loss Magister formance
started to dip North achieve a slew of
subpar results between Atlanta and the
next major and crack of where they
suffered yet another quarterfinal
exclusion at the hands of virtus Pro
this time magic wasn't looking so hot to
try and stave off match point pain they
just had Eagles and tech nights here
oh no and that's the kill from neo
taking down maze it is not looking
trying to see if they can get down by
their standing on some of the fire are
getting shot for the smoke and the
alligator block them off with a small
raiding Cajun goes down
[Applause]
Phillips the water
ironically it was virtus Pro who found
majus crying in the lobby after North
had benched him following their
elimination from the major some
speculated that it was because of his
play others because of what an emotional
player he was Maja's felt as if he'd hit
rock bottom
[Music]
down but not out it wasn't long before
magic was asked to join optic gaming's
new european roster he achieved regional
success in north america but
internationally still struggled to set
himself apart he's waiting he's playing
it patiently my just got no idea the
second purpose is missed ten seconds so
it may not end up mattering so majestic
watch this would pull off some
ridiculous play and it won't be
happening on this time fnatic have done
it to odd and then something happened
that would change the entire course of
Maja's career convinced that Astros was
a sinking ship weeks before he was
supposed to renew his contract the RB
abandoned them to join North I feel
still feel like we're good friends but
it all honesty I we would just have
appreciated a conversation about it
because also still at the moment we
really don't know why when it came to
finding TR B's replacement Astralis
could have had any Dame they wanted they
were major winners after all and despite
device's health problems were still
considered the country's top roster the
overwhelming expectation was that they'd
pick up the biggest Danish star who
wasn't on Astralis convict the issue is
that his role as an entry Fragger
conflicted with that of Dupree so to
everyone's surprise he chose majus no I
didn't expect to join Australia it kind
of came as a shock but I'm happy I got
the chance from them and it was at the
very moment of his joining that
something changed not only within majus
but within a strongest there's the
flashback over yes coz to the way let
the follow-up spray nitro walks right
into it there goes twisting zip mix
here's a increased speed from liquid but
claims gonna get that first kill and
Dupree manages things all in a pistol
whip that's nice they are gonna be
flanked out a good entry from Aegis
though and here's nice well usually
gotta come through the smoke if they
want a chance with
everyone for Miss chalice is just
straight up winning Australis had always
been a tremendous roster so people
weren't necessarily surprised when they
took Dreamhack masters in Marseille in
March of 2018 what they didn't know is
that a straw 'lest had just kicked off
the greatest dynasty in the history of
csgo they went on to win ESL season 7 1b
to sneak in on up they have inspired him
yeah he's gonna get in close finds the
first now just has nap to deal where the
magic is gonna find them both
here he is tucked away in the heart he's
gonna get smoked off there on the bomb
there stick and in tacos on Italy put
together you're champions here in Dallas
at strongness ECS season 5 you can't try
to pick him up but he must get a
composition as well device is coming in
from her back oh he spent the first shot
but the second was good enough for on
one of all of a sudden he perceives it
up in the footsteps that there is is
good for two kills his teammates
Tampines got time to reload bats all the
way towards competition and it makes
himself to get shot in the legs that's
three kills on me
absolutely what's this and the eleague
premiere just find something weird that
a small cat handled another dry pickford
of ice and another opening kill and he's
gonna go for the follow-up he's blind
man just has got an aide kill again the
round is over and why not continue
challenging you're on fire
here's the push-up mid magic fighting as
he retreats out of the land anything but
how has he done that two kills somehow
so man it's your allylic ramier
champions before steamrolling their way
to a second major win in London
[Applause]
obviously the plates with little bit not
sure if he did na'vi don't expect this
the problem is even with our kill this
is a lot of information ding God their
mast is you taking out all right
Learner's hear it chorus trolleys
it became clear that magic was exactly
what astralis had needed to take a group
of habitually inconsistent stars to the
stars to become the best version of
themselves that in picking up this
hard-working but otherwise innocuous
Dane they've achieved some kind of
secret formula
our goal is 100% to win the Grand Slam
it hasn't been done before it's a thing
that would mean a lot to us and it's
also one of our yeah it's basically the
one thing we're playing for right now it
also became clear that a straw list was
exactly what magic had needed to become
the player he always dreamed of in terms
of his mentality you have to use that
nerve is something good and that's what
we try to do all the time and and use it
as something to to make us even better
as players his reputation and Lord knows
in terms of his play so it falls on
matches it he lines up to body's already
finds the timing that's for how about a
fit it's an ace for magic and every once
in a while he'd make a point of
reminding everyone how far he'd come
some super fancy set piece or strategy
it's just a vice getting an angle better
be out from a gist you do absolutely
love to see it with the astrologer go
proudly situated on his chest majus will
go on to rack up seven more first-place
finishes
becoming one of the first players to win
Intel's million dollar Grand Slam and
earned his second consecutive major
title in Katowice but you can't mess
with greatness you can
with history and these guys are writing
it at every event Intel Extreme Masters
champion majors back to back
[Applause]
life had been moving fast is that first
fateful win in Marseille and it was
sometimes difficult to keep track of all
of it you also have been crowned MVP
really this tournament it's not it is
wow this is first MVP ever I'm glad we
were here for that and yet through it
all
Maja's has remained both humble and
hardworking he knows full well that he's
living the dream that he's achieved
Heights which most superstars never will
and has never stopped being grateful for
the opportunity we've been working hard
for like the last so many months that
it's just amazing to see that it finally
pays off and that we actually managed to
go all the way from the qualifier to to
win the actual major so that's just
amazing and at this point it doesn't
matter whether a strong win another
major whether their era continues on
indefinitely or crashes to a halt
they've already cemented themselves as
the greatest team to ever live and it's
all because they took a chance on one
magical board
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages